salut aujourd'hui je suis à lyon et je
suis à l'espace gerson et nous allons
commencer le deuxième opus de la série
expérience mentale
le problème c'est quand je fais une
vidéo expérience mentale pour lancer
puisque forcément ça en deux temps
collecte des données et interprétation
des données donc le premier temps la
collecte des données s'est un peu
fadasse comme vidéo c'est pour ça que je
vous réserve un bonus à la fin de cette
vidéo
c'est un extrait du spectacle
[Musique]
la surprise sur l'objectif réel de
l'expérience parce que si je vous
annonce et tout ça fausse très les
résultats ça je voulais expliquerait une
fois qu'on aura fini à la collecte de
données tu vois le genre je vais vous
demander de répondre à quelques
questions mais pas dans l'espace
commentaire parce que si vous le faites
dans l'espace commentaire il va se
passer deux choses la première c'est que
ça va influencer le choix des hôtes de
ce qu'ils vont lire et la deuxième c'est
que pour récupérer les données c'est une
tannée donc je crée un google forme et
vous allez répondre via ce google former
ou et le google forme dans la
description bien sûr ce qu'on va faire
la même si vous connaissez pas encore le
but sachez que ça n'a jamais été fait
réellement ça n'a jamais été fait de
cette forme là ça n'a jamais été fait à
cette échelle-là la première question
c'est quelle est votre âge moyen
c'est-à-dire que si vous avez 27 ans
vous pouvez mettre 30 arrondir un petit
peu au dessus si vous avez 12 ans mais
tu es 10 si vous avez 32 ans vous mettez
30 également deuxième question quel est
votre film préféré
troisième question et je vous demanderai
de répondre spontanément donc la réponse
qui va venir maintenant à l'esprit c'est
absolument la réponse que vous devrez
mettre dans le formulaire
le formulaire à partir de maintenant ne
doit pas avoir de réflexion mais on
cherche à avoir les réponses spontanées
le plus spontané possible si témoin le
nom d'un super héros et c'est ce super
héros là que vous marquez dans le google
forme ne changeait pas nouvelles
questions spontanées à laquelle vous
devez pas réfléchir et répondre quand on
claque des doigts vous allez me donner
un nombre entre 0 et 100 n'importe
lequel maintenant nouvelle question
voulait me donner n'importe quelle note
de musique entre do ré mi fa sol la si
maintenant nouvelle question donnez moi
le nom d'une grande capitale et dernière
question s'il vous plaît toujours en
réponse spontanée sinon ça n'a pas
d'intérêt pour le test donnez moi le nom
d'un monument célèbre maintenant le
premier qui vaut bien
merci d'avoir joué le jeu ça c'est super
donc en bonus de cette vidéo puisque
l'expérience mentale en elle-même la
collecte des données s'est pas ouf non
plus je vous mets un extrait de l'intro
du spectacle de ce soit intro qui va
bientôt changer dans le spectacle
puisque mandales rodage c'est le
spectacle qui changent en permanence
pour aboutir au nouveau spectacle c'est
parti merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
pourrait tu imagines un poster devant
toi ou un écran de cinéma où tu appelles
une image de ton film préféré si c'est
trop compliqué d'avoir l'image animée
durant dix matches mythiques robien du
film et tu la mets devant toi comme s'il
y avait un poster de ceux de cette image
c'est pour ça que tu fasses ok donc là
là c'est fait
ok alors regardez l'âge comme s'ils
étaient des gardes pour toi tu as pris
une image de n'avoir tout dans le film
c'est ça ok tu regardes cette image de
haute en bas et de gauche à droite
d'accord on va aller très très haut ça
veut dire que ça se passe à l'intérieur
en général si à l'intérieur c'est pas en
extérieur oui d'accord relief oui
si vous regardez le personnage principal
ou l'effacement ce principe possible à
plusieurs d'accord qu'il y avait une
différence de taille celle des hommes
c'est ça d'accord plusieurs scènes
d'ensemble
regarder un petit peu de l'endroit où
ils sont la décoration les meubles ce
genre de choses je suis en images comme
sur ton visage mentalement
en face de toi d'accord gardien regarde
pas des mêmes fini maintenant
ok je vais te demander encore un tout
petit effort tu vas aller au tout début
du film que je vois le générique
s'afficher c'est pas possible on ne peut
pas faire ça passe juste imaginer le
titre du film entre mes mains
si c'est trop gros pour ancrer entre mes
mains tu réduit la taille de la police
mais tu fais tu le dis mentalement comme
s'il était là de gauche à droite tac tac
tac tac aux articles de mots c'est ça
non mais plus de moxa vous demande sa
pièce commence à avoir une bonne idée
alors pris c'est quoi paul je vais dire
le film le film que tu avais là si je me
trompe
tu fais pas de cadeau tu dis non c'est
pas ça si ça ressemble mais c'est pas
exactement saturn et non c'est pas ça tu
t'es trompé je veux pas qu'il y ait
d'ambiguïté avec ça si je me trompe
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave moi ça
va plus soul et de l'autre on peut dire
clairement un bébé c'est pas de ta faute
tu vois c'est que de la mienne je pense
que le film était un fin visualiser avec
tous les mêmes objets je dirais que
c'est la ligne verte s'est quand même
fait la fin d'ici donc je ne sais pas si
j'ai réussi à faire mon intro ce soir
lors des soirées plus dur que en tout
cas moi je vous remercie d'avoir
participé à la collecte des données
s'écoule dans quelques semaines je
reviens avec vous avec les résultats je
vous explique à quoi ça sert et c'est
comme d'habitude pour s'appliquer cette
vidéo vraiment pensé à vous abonner si
c'est pas encore fait et à très bientôt
au début de semaine prochaine ciao